Турецька поліція шукає тіло Джамаля Хашоггі
в лісі біля Стамбула, а також за 90  кілометрів від міста
Слідство обмежило райони пошуку цими ділянками після аналізу
пересувань представників Саудівської Аравії, підозрюваних у вбивстві.
Дедалі більше західних оглядачів та журналістів порівнюють імовірне вбивство
саудівського журналіста та спробу отруєння
колишнього російського агента Сергія Скрипаля.
В обох випадках за злочинами швидше за все стоять
спецслужби авторитарних режимів - Росії та Саудівської Аравії.
Своїми діями російський і саудівський режими посилають
потенційним об'єктам переслідування наступний сигнал:
ми здатні це зробити, ми свідомо на це йдемо
і не дозволимо нікому нас зупинити.
У випадку з отруєнням Скрипаля реакція світової спільноти
була швидкою, згуртованою і рішучою.
США і 18 країн Євросоюзу видворили російських дипломатів,
Вашингтон запровадив санкції щодо Москви.
А на цьому тижні також Євросоюз затвердив режим санкцій
через застосування хімічної зброї,
за цим послідують конкретні санкції за хіматаку в Солсбері.
Однак у випадку Джамаля Хашоггі західне співтовариство
радше вичікує, ніж діє.
Справа із саудівським журналістом надто свіжа,
ще недостатньо перевірені докази,
щоб можна було очікувати реакції.
Але я припускаю або побоююся, що реакція світової спільноти
буде не такою потужною. Тому що особливо американська влада
сильно зацікавлена в тому, щоб не зіпсувати відносини із саудівським режимом.
Президент США Дональд Трамп напередодні заявив,  що саудівського журналіста,
ймовірно, дійсно вбили, і пригрозив Ер-Ріяду наслідками.
Тим часом у Німеччині закликають не проводити паралелі
між резонансними справами Хашоггі та Скрипаля,
а дочекатися результатів розслідування.
Я б застеріг від подібних порівнянь, адже ясно одне:
у справі Скрипаля завдяки роботі слідчих
британська влада за підтримки міжнародних органів
дуже швидко виявила отруйну речовину,
за допомогою якої було скоєно злочин,
а також країну, в якій її виготовили.
А у випадку зі справою Хашоггі можна сказати лише те,
що вже було сказано: необхідно терміново, всебічно і якомога прозоро
розслідувати те, що сталося 2 жовтня.
Нагадаємо, що того дня 59-річний саудівський журналіст
прийшов до консульства Саудівської Аравії в Стамбулі,
щоб оформити документи для укладення шлюбу.
З тих пір його більше не бачили. Але деякі оглядачі
все ж вважають, що порівняння цих двох справ все ж доречно.
Я вважаю, що представник німецького уряду не правий.
Звичайно, можна порівнювати ці дві справи,
тому що в обох випадках відповідальність за ці злочини несуть
спецслужби недемократичних режимів.
Важлива відмінність між ними в тому,
що вбивство Хашоггі відбулося в дипломатичному представництві -
- в Саудівському консульстві в Стамбулі.
Такого практично ще ніколи не було.
Тож, потім заперечувати скоєння цього злочину, звісно, неможливо.
Тим часом, за даними ЗМІ, саудівська влада
може незабаром визнати факт скоєння злочину.
Ер-Ріяд нібито готує заяву, в якій смерть Хашоггі буде названа
результатом невдало проведеної спецоперації з його викрадення.
Допит Хашоггі в консульстві, ймовірно,  назвуть частиною операції,
проведеної без узгодження із саудівською владою.